and i also studied the money that came
into the club i could see the girls that
weren't on the box cover
that did more aggressive scenes the
girls that did anal
they didn't bring in the same clientele
so they weren't making as big i could
see the difference between the blue
collar and between the suits
so i was able to meet as far as
clientele in the club yep and mine break
that down because obviously you guys go
to the club they're there to spend some
money have a good time
break that down who like all right this
guy he's gonna spend some money ah don't
mess with that guy he's a loser this
girl's going to go after that guy break
that down with the money and in the club
you're talking about strip clubs right
now yes strip club
by the way and still in jersey i'm in
reading pennsylvania at al's diamond
cabaret and al's diamond cabaret was my
first nude bar and it was b-y-o-b
so when you're talking about the classes
of money the blue-collar guys would
carry in a keg in a statement
b-y-o-b b-y-o-b i'm telling you how were
they they didn't have liquor license no
liquor license because you couldn't be
nude in pennsylvania with liquor but you
could let them bring in their own so the
guys who had more money would bring in
bottles and would you know pay the
waitress to get them a cup of ice and
lemons and all the things that they
could get um and so you could easily it
was a stark difference so i was
analyzing the whole financial setting of
it remember terry weigle would come in
and she did this incredible show and the
suits that would come in for her lunch
show nobody put down once so i was like
oh man she's only making five tens and
twenties like there's not even a one in
this whole situation the other girls
would come in it was all once
so i just surveyed that and then by the
time i was
21 i was starting to make my first trips
out to california to start meeting
people i still like a place in
pennsylvania wasn't sure are you like on
the wall there do they recognize you as
like
yeah
they do and al put out a lot of features
because he had rules for us
you worked six days a week he was open
six days a week
and sunday's god's day god said
not allowed in pennsylvania just like
you can't buy liquor on sundays in p.a
can't buy a car on sundays and people
wait really you can't buy a car weird
things um and he would make you work a
six day shift and if you wanted a day
off you had to take a week off so what
you'd do is you'd work three weeks and
then you take a whole week off he also
had an accountant come in and help us
with our taxes he also paid us on a
paycheck so that we weren't getting all
cash
um
so he made us he made me a good
businesswoman
at the end of the day we're talking
about dating relationships i know you
have pretty you know strong opinions on
financial stuff and you know i know you
help a lot of the girls in the industry
which we'll get into but was this how
your financial knowledge kind of started
with this guy was his name again al
shout out to al savin that money the
dude we all called him the dude and he
just wasn't going to every other club
paid you under the table they didn't
even know your real name they didn't
want to know anything about you they did
not want to be responsible for you for
him because i remember going there with
my bad id and him saying when you
actually are 18 you can come back here
and work so i wasn't going to be able to
work there oh so you didn't work there
until you were 18 i started working
there
you still made me do amateur night you
got to get up on stage and do this whole
amateur show but
um yes he was who really made me think
about it and also really put me on a
schedule where i could be on the road as
a feature entertainer and take one week
off a month get all of my personal
things done dentist like he would tell
you like you take one week off a month
you get all your personal stuff done and
then you work and the six day work week
was monday tuesday wednesday you either
worked noon to six or six to 12 and on
thursday friday and saturday every girl
had to work noon to midnight
[Music]
you